bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
vidéo 5 mythes sur lui si vous
connaissez probablement lui si le plus
connu de tous les squelette
d'australopithèque au monde mais il ya
certainement plusieurs choses que vous
croyez connaître à propos de l'uci et
qui ne sont pas vraies en voici cinq
premièrement lucie serait le squelette
le plus complet d'australopithèques
jamais découvert c'était peut être vrai
à l'époque où on a découvert lucide le
24 novembre 1974
mais aujourd'hui c'est pau depuis la
découverte du squelette de little foot
attribué à australopithecus prometheus
et qui est complet à plus de 90%
il ne lui manque guère que quelques os
du pied deuxièmement lucie serait
l'australopithèque le plus ancien c'est
aussi faux puisque l'uci est âgé de 3,2
millions d'années alors que little foot
est âgé de 3,6 à 3,7 millions d'années
de plus on a retrouvé au tchad une
mandibule d'australopithecus par el
ghazali qui est âgé de 3,6 millions
d'années aussi ces deux
australopithèques sont donc au moins 400
mille ans plus vieux que lucie numéro 3
lucie serait le tout premier
australopithèques jamais découvert c'est
encore faux puisque l'uci a été
découvert en 1974 alors que le tout
premier australopithecus jamais
découvert est nommé ainsi a été
découvert en 1924 en afrique du sud
il s'agit du tangue child ou en points
de tang qui appartient à l'espèce
australopithecus africanus on notera par
ailleurs que les différences entre
australopithecus africanus donc
l'australopithèque original et lucie
c'est-à-dire australopithecus afarensis
sont elles que certains spécialistes
propose de placer lucide dans un genre
différent prêt entre eux plus ainsi
l'uci ne seraient peut-être même pas un
australopithèque du tout 4e mythe
à propos de lucy lucy était enceinte
quand elle est morte
c'est une idée qui a été popularisé par
le documentaire l'odyssée de l'espèce en
2002 mais en réalité il n'existe aucun
ossement de foetus qui était retrouvée
associée avec l'uci en réalité le
squelette de lucy a même été retrouvé
sur une surface relativement grande pas
du tout en articulation anatomiques
donc il n'existe aucune chance qu'un
foetus et pu être préservée en même
temps plus il même si elle était
enceinte
donc il s'agit encore d'une idée fausse
et enfin cinquième et dernier mit à
propos de lucy lucy a été découverte par
yves coppens
ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai car bien
que hilco passe et fait partie de
l'équipe de la international à paris
sauf expedition c'est en réalité donald
johanson et sommes gré qui ont trouvé le
fossile les premiers le nom de yves
coppens ne figure d'ailleurs pas sur la
première publication faisant mention de
l'existence de lucy
voilà à défaut d'en savoir plus sur lui
si maintenant vous saurez un peu moins
de choses fausses je vous dis à très
bientôt et merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo
[Musique]